Welcome to this English Online
business English series!
We’ll be equipping you with skills
that you can use to navigate
the international English speaking workspace.
Let’s get started. We’re going to
start with a juicy topic.
One that a lot of people like talking
about but don’t really like acting upon.
Conflict Management.
Now there’s a buzzword if
there ever was one.
So, conflict management 101.
Number 1: Assume positive intentions
Okay. This is how we often approach a
conversation in an attempt to manage conflict.
They’re going to try and manipulate
you, but DO NOT STAND DOWN!
It’s like when we’re entering a conversation
that is attempting to manage
conflict, we’re going to war.
Remember, you want to resolve an issue,
sothat you and your team can move forward.
Start by assuming that your colleague’s
intentions are positive. That they’re actually
interested in the well being of the team.
Thetruth is, they’re not looking to humiliate you.
How you think about someone changes
how you interact with that person.
This is an example of when
we assume the worst.
To be honest with you, I really
don’t think it was a good idea.
You’re always looking for what
we didn’t do well.
Quite honestly it stifles
our creativity as a team.
Versus assuming the best
To be honest with you, I really
don’t think it was a good idea.
Okay, You obviously have your reasons for thinkingthat - why don’t you think it was a good idea?
Assume that your colleagues
have positive intentions.
It really will help you manage conflict.
Number 2: Listen and be open to change.
A conversation is two ways. If you’re the onlyperson speaking,
that’s called a monologue,
not a conversation. In a conversation
you need to be speaking and listening.
The problem is, a lot of us think we’re listening
when actually, all we’re doing is waiting
for our chance to respond. I just thought
you were a little bit inconsiderate
when she asked you what you thought of thepresentation
and you were really critical.
Inconsiderate? How is that inconsiderate?
I didn’t want her to get up in front of
our directors with a presentation that was
going to make sure we don’t get the funding.
these kinds of things just so that we
can grow together as a team and really
get to where we need to be.
Person 2: Mm yes, sorry, just to…
go back to when you said that I was inconsiderate,
I just need to say that I really don’t agree.
Remaining silent as we wait for our chance torespond
is not the same thing as listening.
Let me ask you a question. How often
do you prepare your counter attack
whilst pretending to listen? Put your thoughts aside for the moment and
truly listen when your colleague is speaking.
I just thought you were a little bitinconsiderate.
She’s been working on it for a
really long time and I really think that just with
a little bit more encouragement and maybe just
looking out for the positives that it could really
kind of boost her and bring out the best in her.
Growth and development are only possible ifyou allow their words
to change you, and your attitude and your responses.